well I will I will quote Cornel West who
has the best definition of not optimism
but hope he's not as interested in
optimism and neither am i and I must
point out to you that I think your
question is a an American question that
Americans always want to know they
always in our country we always want to
know basically is it going to be alright
I mean that's what you're asking me is
it going to be alright
I don't know however given that fact
I'll quote Cornell who differentiates
between optimism and hope by saying that
optimism looks out the window and says
you know looks pretty good out there
evidence is based on the evidence I
think it's all right it's all right hope
looks at the evidence and says it
doesn't look good
doesn't look good at all I'm going to go
beyond the evidence to create new
possibilities based on visions that
become - that become contagious - allow
people to engage in heroic actions
always against the odds no guarantee
whatsoever and Cornell has respect for
the struggle if the limitations of my
experience gave anything to my lens it
is a love of the struggle and a respect
for the fact that part of the human
condition is that we are struggling the
way that a baby struggles from crawling
to standing to walking so that's a part
of the human condition so then to
embrace not this short kind of idea of
optimism which is it's fine the fact it
looks good let's go but to actually say
it looks bad let's go because if we go
now
even when it's bad we might be able to
imagine something powerfully enough that
we create leadership because people want
to go after that vision of the future
and I do think that what art contributes
to the whole enterprise is that as the
people who have spent time trying to
turn imagination into actions
imagination into objects that many of us
would like to bring especially to be
abused in the time when people only want
to look to see that it looks good and
therefore I'm gonna do what I can count
on many of us would like to make a
suggestion that causes people to try
something hard and to try to go the
other way even if it looks bad